safe moon is getting sued along with
jake paul soja boy and more for an
alleged pump and dump apparently the
moon wasn't safe
the result of this could have shocking
implications for everyone who thought
they could just get out of jail free by
saying not financial advice hold on i
can't promote scams on the internet even
if i say do your own research [ __ ] funny
isn't it how the tables have turned
let's investigate
okay so this is the lawsuit we're
looking at today filed as a class action
lawsuit by these guys they're suing the
safe moon team and several influencers
who promoted safe mode including jake
paul soulja boy little yachty and a
bunch of kind of smaller tier
influencers now what are the allegations
well this quote the misleading
promotions and celebrity endorsements
were able to artificially increase the
interest and price of the safe moon
tokens during the class period causing
investors to purchase these losing
investments at inflated prices okay so
basically they're saying safe moon
succeeded because of all these celebrity
endorsements and investors jumped in at
all-time highs
meanwhile safe moon and the gang were
allegedly selling quote the company's
executives caroni and haines davies
conspired with the promoter defendants
to sell their safe moon tokens to
investors
for a profit now as a reminder safe moon
was a huge deal back in 2021 for a
simple core reason basically safe moon
was safe that's what we were all told
how well because of the liquidity pool
which is a pool of funds supporting the
price of the project it was supposed to
be locked up untouchable for four years
on pancake swap hence we're gonna go
safely to the moon the team wasn't
supposed to be able to touch those funds
they weren't supposed to be able to rug
us but like jeffrey epstein the safe
moon team touched things a little too
early and got insanely rich by doing it
and got away with it for far too long
see the truth is contrary to what had
been pitched to us the project owners
had access to these tokens the liquidity
pool this entire time and could sell
them at any time and did sell them or at
least that's what the lawsuit alleges
now of course who benefited from this
not the investors but instead safe moon
and the influencers who promoted it now
one thing that might be challenging for
this lawsuit is the fact that i'm sure a
lot of these influencers have no idea
what a liquidity pool even is i don't
think they knew what they were promoting
i don't think they cared as long as they
were getting paid now the lawsuit
anticipates this saying this quote they
knew or should have known that the
liquidity pools were designed in a way
that allowed for the possibility of the
liquidity pool being drained by
defendants in other words even if little
yachty thought a liquidity pool was
something you placed a little yachty in
it doesn't matter he's still responsible
for what he promoted or at least that's
the argument they're making now whether
a judge believes it well that's another
thing entirely but this is where things
actually get really interesting see this
class action lawsuit involving
influencers might have better odds than
you might think because of a recent
decision on another case that impacts it
remember bitconnect this guy there's a
very similar story going on there huge
crypto project there were a lot of
influencers who promoted it everything
fell apart and then afterwards there's a
class action lawsuit but in that case it
got thrown out because it was argued
that influencers could not be held
responsible for what they said why
because they didn't actively solicit
investments the argument is basically
that they put it out on social media
generally but didn't directly solicit
from their followers according to the
case quote the securities act covers
sales pitches to particular people not
communications directed to the public so
it seemed like investors might be immune
from cases like this but recently that
dismissal got reversed and the new
ruling came out that said this quote
solicitation has long occurred through
mass communications and online videos
are merely a new way of doing an old
thing in other words these big connects
promoters can absolutely be sued and so
can other influencers with this
precedent it's not a defense to say oh i
didn't dm people i just posted it to my
millions of fans that can still be
considered solicitation and this is why
this lawsuit could be huge especially if
they get the damages they're asking for
notably the difference between what
investors bought and sold safe moon for
this could be tens of millions of
dollars in damages that the team tin
house has to pay for now of course i
wanted to say you know i also thought
this lawsuit missed a few things as well
specifically that two of the founders
thomas smith and kyle negley aren't
mentioned which is a strange omission
and i think we're going to have to help
these guys out in our next episode by
talking about the influencers payments
which is never mentioned in this lawsuit
maybe they don't realize it but all this
stuff is publicly available on the
blockchain and one of these guys wasn't
that careful in covering his trail we're
revealing this influencer and their
wallets in the next episode so pump the
stock if you want to see that thanks for
watching you just want me to look bad on
camera